at a popular tourist spot in Paris
everyone is drawn to a beautiful woman
who walks starkly naked on the sidewalk
everyone is so impressed by the woman's
bravery that they don't notice a cunning
pickpocket stealing their belongings a
while later the pickpocket Michael Mason
meets up with the naked woman revealing
that he had arranged for her to be the
distraction while he hustled the crowd
elsewhere a young woman named Zoe is
hanging out in a hotel with her
boyfriend Jean Jean has placed a bomb
inside of a doll and wants Gene to plant
the bomb at the office of the French
nationalist party Zoe is reluctant to
carry on the plan but Gene charmingly
convinces her Zoe puts on a blonde wig
and heads towards the building she gets
in with a little problem and is about to
leave the bomb when the building's
cleaning crew arrives Zoe's unwilling to
kill the innocent people and walks out
with the bomb she sits on the staircase
and calls Gene she explains the
situation and says she will dump the
bomb in the nearest river meanwhile
Michael scours the streets for his next
Target when he sees Zoe he stealthily
approaches her taking advantage of her
to strong appear parents to steal her
back Michael is deeply disappointed to
see the handbag containing a teddy bear
and an analog phone the phone suddenly
rings and Michael picks it up hanging up
when Jean's voice Echoes from the other
side Michael quickly discards the bag
and walks off a few minutes later the
bomb in the handbag explodes and the
impact knocks Michael off his feet
Jean's boss Rafi Bertrand and another
accomplice Kristoff hear the explosion
even though the bomb goes off at the
unintended spot the impact is fearful
enough for the citizens especially with
Bastille Day being the next day Rafi
calls the French Embassy and informs
them that the bomb is the first of many
that will bring Paris to its knees in 36
hours the head of French intelligence
Victor holds a press release assuring
the citizens that all is safe and that
Bastille Day Parade will proceed as
planned investigations into the bombing
are launched and coincidentally one
security camera caught Michael
discarding the bag his picture is sent
to the Interpol and CIA Sean Breyer is a
CIA agent based in Paris he has a habit
of breaking the the rules and not
following the code of conduct which
earns him reprimands from his bosses
however he gets the job done so the
agency refuses to let him go Sean
quickly learns of the bombing which is
claimed for civilian casualties he gets
Michael's image and within minutes knows
everything about the pickpocket Michael
is an American from Las Vegas born to a
casino Boss Father and a realtor mother
Michael was an excellent student but his
father's untimely demise left him with
substantial gambling debts consequently
he had to drop out of high school and
has been drifting into various countries
committing fraud Sean quickly traces
Michael's apartment using a pay phone
Michael used to call his mother from
when he arrives he finds Michael
attempting to escape from the roof he
steals a bike and goes to a crowded
Marketplace but Sean quickly grabs him
and brings him to the interrogation
quarters Sean accuses Michael of being a
terrorist and demands to know what
organization he is working for Michael
confesses that he had stolen the bag
from a woman wearing a blonde wig oddly
enough Sean believes Michael however he
wants to see how great of a pick pocket
he is so Michael amazes the agent by
stealing his wallet in cash in seconds
Gene is with Zoe in his apartment trying
to calm her down as she holds herself
responsible for the deaths of civilians
suddenly he sees Rafi and Kristoff pull
up outside the apartment he fears that
Rafi intends to kill Zoe as she is
unsteady and might ruin their plans
Sheen quickly advises Zoe to run and lay
low for a few days Zoe escapes through
the back door so Rafi does not find her
he traces Zoe's location using her cell
phone not knowing that Michael has it
Michael is still in the interrogation
room with Sean when Kristoff approaches
the site and disguises himself as a
mailman Sean quickly catches on causing
a fight and Michael to escape Christoph
and Rafi Escape leaving Sean to explain
the situation to his boss Tom Tom is
angry at Sean for disobeying direct
orders as he had been instructed to
bring Michael in not interrogate him
secretly it turns out that Rafi is the
head of a special unit called rapid he
is meeting with Victor when they get an
anonymous call about a threat in a
nearby mosque the rapid team quickly
invades the mosque and gets evidence
that the immigrants are behind the
bombing many immigrants are arrested
causing a nationwide uproar in the
Islamic community meanwhile Michael
seeks out his friend Baba hoping to get
Asylum while everything blows over
unfortunately it turns out that Baba has
been paid by the authorities to sell out
Michael Rapids soon surrounds the house
but Michael cannot Escape as Baba has
locked all doors Michael hides and
manages to hide from the team he runs to
the roof and before a sniper can shoot
him Sean appears and rescues him he
agrees to help Michael clear his name
the only way to do that is to find Zoe
the two find the location where Zoe is
hiding before they can get to her Zoe's
friends rescue her allowing her to
escape and leaving the two men
devastated Sean knows one of Zoe's
friends working in a club so he asks
Michael to try and get the man's
identity card Michael creates a
diversion allowing him to get the man's
address Sean and Michael travel to the
address and find Zoe Zoe agrees to
cooperate with Sean after he points out
that Zoe is not a terrorist but a mere
Courier Zoe tells them about Gene
prompting them to visit his apartment
meanwhile videos of the police beating
up the immigrants start trending on the
internet many riots emerge and agitating
hashtags are targeted at the police Sean
Zoe and Michael get to Gene's apartment
where they find him dead Sean looks at
the hanged body and sees a tattoo on
Jean's arm he puts one and one together
figuring out everything that is
happening he calls his other boss Karen
and tells her everything the rapid team
planned the bombing attack as a
distraction for something bigger
unfortunately Gene the former captain of
Rapid is dead so he cannot back up a
story but he is with Michael and Zoe
Karen then arranges to meet the trio the
following day Karen organizes with
Victor a plan to take Michael and Zoe
into protective custody after confirming
the Trio's location Victor shoots Karen
showing that he is The Mastermind of the
whole operation he shares the location
with Rafi and instructs him and his team
to kill the trio he also reveals that
the online videos and threats are part
of his plan now thousands of protectors
are walking toward National Bank
consequently Victor announces that rapid
will be protecting the bank Sean and Zoe
quickly realized that the men sent to
pick them up are part of the rapid team
Sean quickly beats up a few men allowing
him to take control of the van today is
Bastille Day and Sean figures out
rapid's main plan they intend to rob the
bank of France and get away with it due
to the unrest of the country Sean calls
Tom and informs him about all this Tom
is reluctant to believe that Victor
could betray his country in such a way
seeing that he has no other choice Sean
decides to fight the thugs alone he
drives to the bank where thousands of
protesters have assembled this was part
of Victor's plan as it would allow rapid
full access to the internal security
Sean instructs Michael and Zoe to wait
in the car while he goes inside the bank
rapid has already started its plan by
deactivating all security cameras and
measures they start transferring the
bank's entire monetary reserves
digitally meanwhile Sean is found out by
the team and they start tracking him
Michael and Zoe hear Sean's predicament
over a stolen police radio and decide to
help they start another Riot that causes
the protesters to enter the bank and
attack the police officers this allows
Sean to infiltrate the bank and stand
alone with Rafi in the remaining
henchmen a fierce fight ensues in which
Sean kills most men and only Rafi
remains Rafi gets a call from Victor who
wants to abort the mission but Rafi
claims it to be too late as the money
500 million euros has already been
transferred into a flash drive Rafi
threatens to take Victor down with him
if he betrays him Sean advises Michael
to use his pickpocketing skills and grab
the flash drive from Rafi when Rafi
realizes the drive is missing he holds
Zoe hostage and threatens to shoot her
unless Michael appears at the same time
Victor orders the police to shoot Rafi
as he has received information that Rafi
is corrupt following rafi's death all
other members of Rapid are arrested
Victor receives an award for bringing
down the criminal and corrupt police
Syndicate since Michael is still missing
Victor does not enjoy his glory and
peace he reaches out to Baba and asks
him to tell Michael buyers interested in
the drive Michael meets up with Victor
who will give him one hundred thousand
dollars in a passport in exchange for
the drive Michael agrees to the terms
and the two walk down a basement Victor
talks about the heist and removes his
gun to shoot Michael suddenly he is
surrounded by Sean and other police
officers as Michael lures him to get a
confession Victor is arrested and
Michael celebrates click on one of the
two videos on your screen right now
foreign